Olympia does not know right now that I
am pregnant so the big reveal will be at
the Met and then before we leave I'll
tell Olympia yeah turns out Little
Olympia Ohanian learned she was becoming
a big sister just as the world found out
too
[Applause]
with Serena Williams debuting her baby
bump at the 2023 Met Gala she broke the
news of baby number two on Instagram
just before hitting the carpet thanking
Anna Wintour for inviting her her
husband Alexis Ohanian and their baby to
be to Fashion's biggest night
but according to Serena their little
girl wasn't in the know and for a good
reason Olympia does not know right now
that I am pregnant the reason I haven't
told her is because she can't keep a
secret Serena shared that clip to her
YouTube channel Friday explaining when
they planned to spill the beans so the
big reveal will be at the Met and then
before we leave I'll tell Olympia safe
to say Olympia knows she's gonna be a
big sister now the most rewarding thing
is just seeing her smile every day it
makes me so happy as for Serena she
loves being a Mama I've always wanted to
be a mom you know but I never seem to
have time I was always working with my
career and then stove right in and it's
so natural for me I love it I love her
so much and you know it's we have a
great little family going on back in
2018 Serena opened up to ET about
balancing her career and motherhood
working method is real it's so real but
I have my priorities in Olympia is that
I'm never a day without Olympia like
she's my priority and every day I like
need to be home with her because I don't
I don't want to miss any moments with
her Flash Forward to last year Serena
announced she's stepping off the court
and earlier this year she told E.T she's
not even watching the sport on TV I
haven't actually been watching because
I'm not sure how I'm gonna feel this is
the first Grand Slam that I'm purposely
not in like I just don't really want to
watch because I'm not trying to get the
bug
um so we'll yeah so I haven't watched
too much Serena's Focus has been on
family for a while and it seems her
dreams in that department are coming
true I definitely want to God willing so
I'm gonna wait and see what happens
foreign